exactement les députés européens ont
voté à bulletin secret et le résultat
c'est 400 voix pour le oui 248 pour le
non et 45 abstentions
l'immunité parlementaire de carless
couche damon est bel et bien levé alors
il faut rappeler que l'ancien président
catalan est poursuivie en espagne pour
avoir organisé en 2010 est un référendum
indépendantiste interdit en catalogne
et donc depuis plus de trois ans il
s'est exilé en belgique afin d'échapper
à la justice
alors l'homme avait été avait été élu au
parlement européen en mai 2010 9 mai un
nouveau mandat d'arrêt a été émis contre
lui
à l'automne dernier pour sédition et
détournement de fonds publics donc le
juge du tribunal suprême espagnol
souhaite l'auditionner pour ces faits
qui remontent à 2017 il avait donc
demandé au parlement de bruxelles de
lever l'immunité
alors désormais avec ce résultat les
conséquences ça va être que l'espagne
pourra réactiver le mandat d'arrêt
européen qui avait été suspendu en
janvier 2020 mais l'extradition ne va
pas être aussi simple puisque dans un
premier temps l'ancien président catalan
a déjà déclaré qu'il allait mener une
bataille judiciaire afin de faire
annuler le la levée de l'immunité et
puis de l'autre
la justice belge pourrait éventuellement
refuser l'extradition vers l'espagne car
voir le placer la justice belge s'est
opposé à plusieurs reprises à
l'extradition d'anciens dirigeants
indépendantistes
alors la situation pourrait donc se
reproduire et il faut rappeler que les
anciens dirigeants indépendantistes qui
eux qui sont restés dans le pays
purge actuellement de lourdes peines de
prison